キャンプにいい
駅さーん
ああああい
こんな肇社長ですまったく最近など僕の話になるんですけどもゆるキャンっていう
アニメの女の私はキャンプするある意味があるんですけどもそれを見た瞬間どうしても
キャンプん一緒になってしまったので今から私1人でそうキャンペーンですこれ一人
できます登録キャンペーンです覚えてくださいね一人キャンプリエってきます
いやそうなんですよ経験が全くないんですよねほんとゆるキャン見るだけでめちゃ曲
情報が入ったんだからキャンプで何すればいいのかとかどうやってが楽しいのか何を
持っていけばいいのかなぁいろいろわかったんで
勢いがしますだいぶもう春であったが医師もう何かあってもまぁなんとかなるキャンプ
食べていいかな
心配なんですけどまぁなんとかなると思うよね私今からひっ
おいでそのキャンに行ってみようだ青いないうちのとーさん結構キャンプ大好きで何回
月ビデってもらったんですけどもまぁともに手伝いしたことないんですよたまーになる
日を押すちょっとするぐらいで後ほんとなんもわかんなくて士郎ドナーの素人なんです
けどもうそれでも心からキャンプしたって今思ってるんで早速キャンプ行ってみたいと
思いますとりあえず昨日の子にですねその境に必要なものを買っておきました
テーブルです
一人をなんでこれぐらいなさいっていいですショーコンパクトですチェア
コロチャーフォントで可能もっと強度が少ないようなすごいマットですあ山岳であるん
で結構必須っぽいユイケンネルってたり起こしオーナーあれ卓上グリルこれを受けも
小さめですげーメッツゴン博徒で超いい時とかな人がいろいろ入ってますそのてつの
コップを使いたかったアルミ用のソロクッカー
ペットこれよりできるみたいですよくわかんないけどお箸をさがゴミ袋とか色々でその
ライトです3つは絶対入らないちょっと動画とるんで一応たくさん買ってきました
カッコ様へすごくねこれは3つグレードが大丈夫だと思いますこれが大事シュラフ
める場所ですよはるなんでそんな家族ないと思うんですけどちょっとあった雷と準備し
ました食品系はまたあとでお知らせしますブースでこちらがテントなんですけどもう
ちょっとこれまずや売店でなんであとでちゃんと開けますというわけでこんな感じで
結構コンパクトにまとまったと思うんですけどもこれだけあれば基本的に揃い
キャンであの何日かをいけると思いますぶっこんでちょっと初めてなに1泊しかしない
んですけどもうちょっとゆるっと
楽しんでいければいいなと思っていますでは違いますかもよ
服装だけは一人前
というわけでキャンプ場をつきました
ご覧ください本当に無誰もいないんですよこの時期ここが全部キャンプゾーンになっ
てるんですけども今日のお客さん僕の開けなんで使い方でです結構ばの寒いんであの
チャンスですねもうちょっと誰にもバカ兄さん本当は何も知らないんだから変な事じゃ
バカにされるのだけど一番やなんですよキャンプのプロみたいな人も居るとちょっと
恥ずかしかったんですけども今日誰もいないんであの思う存分素人さ
おぎゃーん楽しみたいと思いますではテント作ってみましょう
今回僕が染まるテントはこちら amazon で見つけがですけども
12人用のテントです
贅沢ななんか一人様でねポツンデフォル業もしたかったんですけども約22人用の超
巨大テントで一人でそれからするのもまた一つの路盤かなと思いまして今回はこんな超
巨大なテントを準備しました
それでちょっともう夕方に良いくれてきてるんで早速テントを作っていきたいとおもい
ます
ソロキャンキッチンエイドその12人夜電と一人で立てるかどうかなんです今日の
ポイントはそこで乗り切れば何かわかると思います
アーサー
あのなんとなんでは触ってみた感じなんですけども
1人じゃあ
作れません
ここで早くも一つなだめますねそのキャンセル時は一人で作れる点同会は省の簡易的な
やつ
これマジで多分で2人でも作れるかどうかわかんないけどめっちゃでかいんですよねだ
けどちょっと協力しながら作っていこうと思います
そのキャン修理を
[音楽]
やばいぞさーん
大丈夫です小足たああああっっっ
をいらっしゃる完璧今後4しま ad
[音楽]
浮いてうんてきたねー
こういうのをねだったらの問題のほかのあの
それっていくこれがはなんだよ
[音楽]
分
ああもうマックなんですけどキャンプができるまで1時間それもソロじゃねえ c
2人で二時間かかりましたーーー
バックラん
ああああああ
はいというわけで無事テントに入り込みました
癒しロー天候もよるどうしようとりあえずマップ-がそれ何していいかわかんないで
また引きます
cnc 加工範囲多分てこれは役立ってくれるらしいんですよ
これらがサイズで絶対いいと思ういいぜ全然こんなもんで俺らでやってくると思ってる
んですねはやめ外で寝るのとかマジどれ帰った無趣味なんだろうな
ん
はいうわぁ左右めっちゃも役立つ一ル
2,010円だったんですよお料理っていう間だしないんですけど外で飯食いたいと
思っている多分ここらへん使うと思います
[音楽]
じゃあまた別のキャンプの人がさいるならいいんですけど
思っ
ゼロなんですよやばい俺多分その拳の中のその気がしてますよちょっと行けテント戻り
まー
year
あとあのようなのキャンプゾーン冷えますねを持って出るはるかに寒くてちょっと実は
結構ヤバいんですよ
あっをタダで食べは何とかちょっといろいろ持ってきたんで早速見てみましょう
事実僕自身も料理ができる人間ではないってことはわかってるんで保存食です水入れる
だけで食べられるご飯22年の電子レンジとかもないから結構苦しい環境よってボン
カレーと
具材ももカットしてるぞ買いましたねちょっとすごい簡単そうに見えるんですけど皆
さんよく考えてみてください
c を起こさないの何もできない世界なんだよキャンプっていうのはすごい残念そうに
ミドルで結構難しいなと思ってる人頑張ってみようと思いますじゃあ火起こし場所に
行ってきます
[音楽]
はここですの
どこ行っんだ
[音楽]
おーわー yoshiki 数そして亜美あという小さいお子せれば何か出来そうな気
がするので何か見つけてきます
やっぱりございます
氷プライスで歌っていました
[拍手]
おやすみなさい
2だけで貼れる一人になってしまいましたはじめ社長ですかね23が結構情報を英断で
ずれずちょっと頑張ってみようと思います
いうてやることはめちゃくちゃ簡単です
[音楽]
[拍手]
オープンのかなぁ
めちゃまとめちゃいます
本当にちょっと呼ばれ自信がないん
入っております
[拍手]
もうやばいつまり音が止まりますねホワイツを入れていきます
グー入って山待てや音がなく入ってるん
パラパラなんだかね頭はねうんを持ってやろうと違うけどまあいいや
先生がこれが俺の実力いいんです
きっと外で食べれば何でも美味しいんです
[拍手]
めちゃくちゃ失敗したんすけど話しすぎてもどうでもいいいただきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
伊木てだヨガっ
[音楽]
いただい上がります
重要ちゃんとまず僕は本当にあえて挙げるとツッコミどころばかりの一日目だったん
ですけどもひとまずこれで飯も食って
でも立ててもう
手紙てほしいんだこれ電波はずっとないんですよ本当に
霊園に入らないでデートも入んなくても起用のビタめちゃくちゃ寒い2歳学んだ普通に
行け真っ白なぐらい寒いんで普通に増えです
そろそろ寝ようと思いますや蔑視のうまかったねほんとに行ったらテント作るのも飯
作るも手伝ってもらったんですけども
なんとか自分の手でやってる感がすごいあってなんかめっちゃ楽しい
というわけで今日もう寝ようと思いますでが電波内のやばくね
まあそれがキャンプってもいいよ嫌なまあ照度たーーーー聞こえたか俺もうマジで
目を終えてください
[音楽]
あのちょっとねぇオート頑張ってみたんですけど
寒いとなんとかすし楽の奥に潜るしかないとねちょっと寒
結構既婚だろうになぁ
これが
キャンプ
あの寒すぎで一睡もできません
やばい本当に寒い俺やばいヒートテック2枚重ねちってたズボンも今2枚入ってですよ
熱い立つそれでも寒くて寝れないってどんだけサウィンだっていう感じですね寒さ対策
不足ですねこのレベルで驚くぐらい寒いです
藪を得まい近畿需要に隠していた
服をさらにしますこれではヒートテックヒートテック方位にもパーカーんさんに福をも
依存いってアウターを着てるって状況ですこれで寒くて寝れなかったら
を恥です
[音楽]
ダムよサブや家三部の
クソ鳩はいなくてよかった生きてて生きてて文書だったん
ああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
いただきます
馬
[音楽]